yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a nice video to make because I'm
giving away some Christmas presents yeah
they won't reach you on Christmas Day
that's too late for that but you can at
least enter this contest to win a book
yeah one of my books
keep it simple efore or d4 as you see
them here right on my bookshelf and I
have a couple of copies of both of them
so I'm going to give away some of the
books roughly ten to fifteen yeah it
sounds a little bit odd because it
depends a little bit on what you choose
yeah you the only thing you have to do
is you have to go to this page the link
is of course in the description of the
video and then you only have to enter
your email I need to contact you in some
form and you should click one of the
radio buttons what you want to win
EP for d4 or you don't care these are
the three options and I'm not quite sure
why I'm sending away like 10 or 15
somebody because of how many entries I
get for each type I have got much more
affordable CS till then d4 book so if
all of you want to get default it gets a
little bit a little bit short on those
so we will see what happens but I'm
giving away like 10 to 15 books
note that this contest is only on for a
little bit more than four days yeah you
should do it on one of the Christmas
days yeah once Christmas is over I'm
closing the contest and then I am going
to yeah draw the winners and yeah get
those books out too yeah probably yeah
get them to you early in 2020 I don't
know it depends on where you live if
you're in New Zealand it will take a
while but if you're in Germany or other
European countries it will probably two
in the first week of January so make
sure to take part in the contest there's
really no catch them I'm not collecting
your email sending you I don't know
stuff that you don't want absolutely and
not doing that so make sure to check out
the link in the just
and enter the contest on a different
note I only learned yesterday that
chasuble is doing another sale for two
of my courses the keep it simple D for
and fight like magnets course so they
make Christmas sale of the most popular
courses of the year so if you want to
get those again a good opportunity to do
that I didn't know that until yesterday
and it's kind of coincidence that this
is now in one video but so make sure to
get them on chess table or on you can
win the print copies right from me make
sure to enter the contest and I'll be
back on the 27th I guess with the
drawing of the winners thanks a lot for
watching and Happy Holidays